so actually I'm gonna I might ask
somebody from the audience anybody want
to hear want to throw out like a answer
of what a blockchain is this guy was
smiling so like I don't know if he
wanted to tell me guys could we please
use the microphone I've got one up here
if someone could just pass it down for
me cool now we're gonna really put you
on the spot with the microphone is it a
hash to linked list so yeah so kind of
like fundamentally it's like kind of a
hash linked list of transactions right
so that's that's kind of a really cool
very like very technical answer but that
doesn't really tell us like what what is
a real blockchain so I'm gonna probably
put this away here so I don't get
feedback so who here has heard of like
something like Bitcoin has anybody heard
of Bitcoin obviously most of this room
probably why you're in this talk so
everybody thinks block chains are just
about transferring currency and
transferring like data between users so
like I kind of want to like show that we
can use actually blockchain for a lot of
other things kind of what I'm most
interested in if I can actually get I
guess this thing is this thing is gonna
just really just mess with me here what
what are some other really interesting
things that block chains can do that we
can't do with other technologies and you
know we have money transfer things like
Bitcoin we have immutable Ledger's so
like if we want to keep track of
balances between multiple parties so
like let's say that we're building a
stock exchange among people that we
don't trust we can build a ledger of buy
and sell orders between a hundred
different parties and we can ensure that
we can trust them through a blockchain
the area that I'm most excited about and
that I work on the most is game assets
like how many people here are gamers
anybody here a gamer like only okay half
the room okay I was a little bit worried
there we're at a programming conference
so what I really think is interesting is
is that what if we owned the characters
that are in the game what have we owned
the swords or the shields that we have
the game what if they were actually
digitally ours what if we could sell
them what if we could trade them and
this is like I think one of the most
exciting things that the blockchain has
to offer and what's really kind of
growing right now is this stuff called
tokenized equity what if we could take a
start-up and instead of just issuing
shares we issued tokens and these open
these tokens could be traded in lieu of
equity and we could have liquidized
exchanges of equity for startups I think
this is probably the most profitable
area right now and block chains and
you've probably heard a lot about this
you've heard about icos and stuff like
this and this is kind of the area that's
kind of probably the most heated and
debated and I probably think what's kind
of really should be exciting to this
audience is there's new ways to monetize
protocols so like used to be when we
built a protocol we built TCP we built
DNS you couldn't make money the guy that
wrote TCP the guy that wrote SMTP they
couldn't make money off of a protocol
but it's kind of interesting about
blockchain protocols is you can actually
have economic models behind them you
could actually charge usage like say if
we built an SMTP on top of a blockchain
we could actually have built in a
payment mechanisms for sending or
receiving emails does it make sense I
don't know but there's definitely a lot
of really new opportunities that really
didn't exist before
so before we step back there's obviously
two big block chains obviously Bitcoin
we saw about 15 people here in the
audience knew about Bitcoin but the
thing that I'm kind of more excited
about is aetherium which is also written
and go or the main implementation is has
anybody here actually got into play with
aetherium oh cool only about four or
five people so awesome I I really I'm
really excited to tell people more so
kind of what blocked change used to be
was Bitcoin I can transfer money to you
you can transfer money to me we can
trade money but what if we had a
universal programming language on top of
the blockchain what if we could write a
piece of code that was a contract that
ran in a decentralized manner so that
way we could have
piece of code that says on Thursday the
27th I'm gonna release $100 to him or
I'm gonna transfer this money to this
person or if you send me this much money
I will give you these items in a game
and all of a sudden we can have a
decentralized computer that everybody
can use and now we're kind of at the
stage where we're trying to figure out
now that we have this decentralized
computer what kind of interesting
applications can be built on top of it
and before we get on before we just to
give the audience alike a little bit of
background about a blockchain is that
they're really just a specialized
database you can kind of think of it as
a linear eventually consistent database
that only allows one transaction at a
time and the transactions have to be
ordered and they have to be they're
always going to be consistent across all
the nodes what kind of where it kind of
deviates from a traditional database is
that multiple different parties will run
the nodes so somebody in China somebody
in America somebody in South America
could be running different nodes and
those nodes of the database are working
together but we have economic incentives
that will to make it so that people
can't cheat other people and we have all
kind of hip cryptographic means to make
this happen and we're kind of good and
delve into that throughout this talk so
first off one of the ways I like to
think about block chains is from kind of
kind of traditional app development is
like the sea rqs model right where
basically everything in a blockchain is
we have we have some kind of transaction
that comes in we're going to write to
our mutable state whether that states of
ledger it could be it could be an
application it could be a smart contract
and then we're just going to create a
materialized view up into that point in
time even though block teams are
immutable in the sense that we can never
never remove transactions from the
history we always have a materialized
view of the current state
of all the blockchain so it's still very
similar to traditional architectures in
that aspect but one last place where
block chains deviate from regular
databases is in regular databases we
just have transactions right so we have
you know like I update a row in the user
table I insert this record I delete this
record but we also have blocks because
we'll be propagating these this data
across thousands of machines across
hundreds of countries we want to like
kind of organize these transactions into
logical blocks to make it a lot more
efficient to send it over the network so
a lot of times like a Bitcoin will have
a one megabyte one megabyte blocks so we
may have 100 200 transactions per block
and that's why they're called block
chains because we organize our
transactions into blocks and that makes
it easier to cryptographically sign them
and transmit them so cool you're like
Matt ok cool I kind of got the idea of
like you know the very basics and I know
I'm kind of running through fast because
I'm trying to explain a whole industry
here in a 40-minute talk but what is
really fun and for me it's games and
kind of what my startup is doing is
actually building games on the
blockchain and I don't know if anybody
here has ever tried to run a game on the
blockchain but most of the games in the
blockchain are incredibly boring Ponzi
schemes essentially so but what's really
kind of cool is the blockchain kind of
opens up a lot of new possibilities
so traditionally like let's say that we
used to have a video game like a server
based game like an a World of Warcraft
or Ultima Online or something like this
the users wouldn't have access to their
data in blockchain everybody can see all
the data that happens in the game if a
user wants to fork the game and create
their own blockchain they can literally
just take the entire data set run their
own instances of the game and add a
certain version of the code and we also
have real ownership of assets
so what I do is actually I build a
battle card game kind of like
hearthstone but on the blockchain but
what's kind of cool is now people can
own the cards it's kind of like when you
were in high school or at least when I
was in high school we actually played
this game called Magic the Gathering and
we literally would trade cards with our
friends or we would bet cards on batches
right so we go back to this era where we
actually have ownership of our digital
items and the items are digitally scarce
and what's pretty cool is because all
the data is on the blockchain you could
actually mine all the games and find out
the best strategies you could do like
chess rankings for video games and if
you wanted if you wanted to change how
this game works you could literally just
fork our blockchain and run your own
instance of the blockchain and run it
with different data or we could even
allow you to upload new smart contracts
to our blockchain so it's kind of the
next evolution I think of kind of
server-side gaming so I want to step
back for a second and talk about the new
is the hotness right now which is the
service which is serverless programming
everybody's always talking to me about
service like that service is the future
so you can think of like programming on
the blockchain is the exact opposite of
service so like with server lists we
have like a single function that runs
and we try not to mutate any state or we
try to we have like a very kind of
stateless service what blockchain we
have like a single function that runs
but all it does is mutate state
it's literally like embedded in the
database so we can think of it like
we're almost building our entire
application into the database which is
kind of like the anticip like everything
we've learned up into this point so it's
kind of interesting so we now have these
things called smart contracts has
anybody here I'm gonna just throw this
at the audience here but has anybody
here ever written a smart contract or
played with one this one guy cool - what
did you make with your smart contractor
what was your opinion
one was omni theorem a token created
registry so we have a self curating list
and a lot of yeah enterprise smart
contracts so shared business logic
basically that's cool so what what is a
it's good there's only two people here
that have written a smart contract I'm
hoping after this talk everybody go and
try to write one smart contract maybe
not and go but there's solidity or
something like that and just try it out
but basically what a smart contract is
it's a program that runs on the
blockchain so what happens is you upload
your program onto the blockchain as
actually data in the blockchain and you
send a transaction to that contract and
when you send that transaction it
actually executes
so your smart contract could send tokens
to other people it could create new
tokens it could store data it can do any
kind of thing that's digitally possible
inside of the blockchain so that's cool
so let's step back just really quick
about me I'm the founder of Loom Network
we kind of build blockchain SDKs and go
so we're big fans of go I used to be
over a digitalocean if you've seen me
before and I wrote a elephant to my
wedding it's just kind of a random fun
fact about me it's kind of a oh yeah and
I flew here 14 hours from Thailand so
I'm not sure did anybody here fly
farther to come here than me or nope
maybe Cory how far did you fly eight
hours very close huh cool and one other
thing is if you guys want to know more
about blockchains programming
blockchains you can pick my year after
the conference or we actually have a
hackathon this weekend here in London
that's kind of why I'm here so you guys
are all welcome I'll sneak you guys in
even if you haven't registered and you
can find out more about actually coding
apps on the blockchain so cool so you're
like Matt okay cool alright so this
blockchain thing sounds kind of
interesting smart contracts okay
whatever
what does this have to do with go why
I'm here for a go conference Matt talk
to me about go so we build all of our
blockchain technology and go and I kind
of wanted to like dig down a bit and
talk about what does it actually look
like and go what are the actual
fundamental pieces that are actually
building these blockchain so you have
just a better conceptual understanding
when you go to write your own smart
contracts
so this ir is going to kill me here so
so basically a smart contract is a
really really really simple interface
and I'm sure you can't actually read
that from the back of the room so don't
worry all all kind of go through it so
really there's only two methods on a
smart contract there's a call and then
there's a static call so basically there
are transactions that are writable and
there are transactions that are
read-only so with a blockchain
transactions that are really are always
free because every single node and the
blockchain has the entire state of the
world so it's very cheap and free to
have read-only state so it's very
important to differentiate if a function
is going to support reading or writing
and what we have to do is a smart
contract is very condensed and what it
can do it can only read data write data
to different keys and basically that's
it but some of those keys for example
are transferring tokens or calling other
functions and other smart contracts so
if I want to transfer tokens from me to
him I can actually call a function in
another smart contract and all that
function does is ultimately change the
values in the ledger of moving the data
between the two people what's kind of
really interesting about smart contracts
is this has to be a hundred percent
deterministic you can't have any code in
here that would ever run differently on
any node so if anybody here's ever run
like a Cassandra instance and you know
that like your data is kind of someone
sometimes different on different nodes
and like sometimes that's okay you can't
do that on the blockchain so literally
after every single commit on a
chain you have to you generate a hash of
that commit and if it doesn't match on
the other nodes and you have to throw
away the data and you consistently do
that on every single transactions so the
there's always very very strong
consistency on the data on the on the
actual blockchain itself and what and I
kind of wanted to also kind of show what
a smart contract looks like and go you
won't see most of these because right
now most people are writing smart
contracts and solidity but that's what
we're trying to change we're trying to
make more blockchain development be done
and go so if we look at a contract here
this is like a really simple contract
that can set and and get data and it
also is emitting events so so basically
it's very simple we're just setting keys
reading keys and we can emit Trentham it
turns out emit data so like sometimes
what will happen is you'll send a
transaction on to the blockchain and
you'll want events back from it like
okay the event I transferred these
tokens to this user or this person now
owns this asset and these are the kinds
of things that we can actually write in
a smart contract and it's just really
really simple go class right but here is
where go actually is one there's a
there's a bunch of downfalls of why go
is actually not the best language for
doing smart contracts so we talked about
determinism before and what is the
biggest issue with determinism
randomness what is the biggest weird
thing that go does that's random is the
ordering of maps so like you're writing
it you're like oh man this is great my
code is actually 10 times faster when I
write it and go instead of solidity it's
all fast and then all of a sudden you're
like oh all my nodes don't come to
consensus because I'm using go maps and
the order is random and now the output
of my data is random and you never
thought about that before because if if
stuff is slightly different on different
nodes you never really cared that much
in in most programming but because
you're you're trying to do a hundred
percent deterministic code it starts to
run into
shoes so the other thing is time we
don't realize this but we use time a lot
in our programming and you can't use
time at all in a deterministic program
the only time you get is access to what
was the time of the last block because
that's a deterministic value so and we
can't use go routines we can't have
threading any kind of threading is
non-deterministic by nature so you can
only do a single threat of execution and
you have to have a very limited
programming set but you get the
advantage that go ends up being about 10
to 100 times faster than other smart
contract programming languages because
it's natively compiled so I would be and
lost not to talk about solidity
so normally solidity is the number one
programming language for smart contracts
I haven't talked much about it because
we're at a conference for go and I've
seen some other blockchain talks at NGO
conferences and I really wanted to show
that go is actually very capable of
doing block chains but I do want to talk
about solidity so if anybody here ends
up deciding they want to get into
blockchain development it's really
important to start trying out solidity
and solidity is kind of like one of
these Harbor languages like JavaScript
that somebody wrote over a weekend like
probably half awake and it ended up
being the de-facto programming language
it's not very good but it's very
available so like if you use the
etherium blockchain you'll you'll see
this language called solidity and it's
kind of a hybrid of javascript looking
but it doesn't have any
non-deterministic features which is
really nice and it also doesn't have
floating point math which I didn't
realize but floating point math is also
non-deterministic because it works
differently on different CPUs and like
there's an amazing amount of things when
you start to get into this you realize
that you never realized before actually
really matter that we're actually
deterministic and we're causing little
tiny issues everywhere but you just
didn't know and it didn't matter that
much right cool awesome
how do I start that we've been talking
about like what are the internals of a
blockchain what is a smart contract how
do I get started and like I said like if
you just want to get started you just
want to play with this and you just want
to play this tomorrow just grab a
theorem which is written and go but use
their language solidity just try that
that's really easy but if you want to
have fun because we're go develop errs
and we want to build our blockchain and
go there's actually a couple frameworks
so not to plug our own stuff but there's
ten Derman which is probably the most
popular go framework for doing building
your own blockchain so it's a it's like
you can think of it as like almost at
the raft or like at the consensus layer
and it has all the primitives you would
need to build your own custom blockchain
and go and then we have our SDK which is
kind of like a layer above it which
provides like go smart contracts above
it and there's a few other ones but
basically I would start with something
like tender mint which is like really
low level and you can kind of really get
to see how blockchain really works
because I think what's going to be
really the big win from the NGO
community is basically go has been
building all the infrastructure of the
web right we've seen that the number one
DNS server on the internet isn't go a
lot of the new HTTP servers are written
and go a lot of the major almost every
single metric system now is written and
go so I think we're gonna see more and
more of the block chains be written and
go and I kind of hope that this is a
gateway where if you see a blockchain
project in the future that will see that
actually all the core infrastructure
will be written and go I would be remiss
not to talk about economics so the thing
about block chains and that they kind of
very different cuz you're like well why
is this really different than a regular
database it's because we have economic
incentives and different chains have
different models for economic for
economy so for example with Bitcoin or
aetherium
every time you send a transaction on the
network you pay a fee and that's how
they ensure that you're not going to
spam the network and then the network
has money to pay for itself right so
it's kind of like this self-perpetuating
computer because every time somebody
does something on it they're paying so
that means that all the people that are
running the computers the miners that
are actually running the chain they're
making money and that's how they're able
to continue running this world computer
because it costs money on each
transaction right so a blockchain that
has no fees and no economic model isn't
a blockchain because ultimately you'll
have no security but there is kind of
some alternate models where like either
the people that write the smart
contracts pay or sometimes the users
will hold a certain number of tokens as
as equity or bonding so there's a kind
of whole slew of economic models but
like the economics is actually one of
like the biggest areas of the blockchain
both from the math and from like just a
pure game theory perspective yep oh and
so it's like I I kind of want to talk
about it but it's a it's a whole talk in
itself that there's different models so
like probably people have seen things
like proof of work and right now most of
the block chains are built on this
method where there's like a
cryptographic puzzle that has to be
solved and if you solve this
cryptographic puzzle like every 15
seconds you win a Bitcoin but that's
what secures the network and it makes
sure that people are spending computing
resources and making sure that the
network is secure there's other models
like proof of stake which is coming out
where it says I'm gonna hold a hundred
bitcoins and because I hold a hundred
bitcoins it's I'm very much less likely
to attack the network and if I do to
attack the network or I do try to cheat
the network the network will take some
of my bitcoins back so there's like a
lot of really interesting models around
economy Oh consents
this is a big big topic I know Cory's
big raft guy just out of curiosity has
anybody here actually had to like delve
into raft or actually use it directly
you have what did you have to use raft
for by the way that is good I don't
think the mic heard that but she said
that she used wrath to tell everybody
that it wasn't appropriate for a project
I'm gonna go ahead and tell you right
now you probably don't need to use raft
unless you're building your own database
and then all of a sudden you do need to
use about maybe maybe if you're gonna
build your own database from scratch and
go or if you're gonna build your own
blockchain from scratch which very very
few people do but it's still a fun
project to work on right so that's when
you start to get into things like
consensus that's when we start to talk
about things like paxos and like we've
used probably zookeeper and all these
kind of technologies so like obviously
probably the most popular one in the NGO
world is raft right and I'm sure a lot
of people have actually seen this where
basically what happens is that there's
different leaders and most consensus
systems work on the principle that
there's different leaders and at
different points in time different
leaders are actually committing the
state into the database right and then
everybody else verifies that that leader
is correct and there's like something
usually a voting system that determines
that says okay know that leader is
actually cheating or as he's malicious
now most systems like raft and Paxos
really don't have much in the way of
maliciousness because they're usually
run on private networks by groups of
peers of things that are not trying to
attack each other they're generally
speaking trying to be good neighbors
sometimes we'll just have wrong results
but they're not generally speaking
people aren't trying to attack the
network but what's kind of interesting
is with the blockchain stuff there's
kind of another level which we call
Byzantine fault tolerance
and Byzantine fault tolerance is kind of
like another level of consensus where
we're actually saying we actually
believe that there's going to be bad
actors we believe that there are gonna
be nodes in our database that are
actively going to try to steal data
manipulate data or do any kind of bad
number of things to the network so with
Byzantine fault tolerance you have you
you have like a voting system we're on
each block each block contains a set of
transactions and we actually have to ask
three-fourths of the nodes are these
blocks correct are these blocks valid
and if we start to have people that
cheat us we won't let their transactions
in unless they take over an overwhelming
majority of the network which at that
point they own the network anyways but
if they do start to cheat us we start to
steal we take their resources so we
penalize you so like if you're a bad
node we actually penalize you so we'll
take some of your Bitcoin or we'll take
some of your etherium back and that's
how we actually create a network that
has consensus with bad actors and people
that are actually because there's
actually big economic incentives so if
you look at a blockchain like aetherium
there's probably a billion dollars worth
of value on the blockchain so if
somebody could steal a million dollars
by having bad code they would probably
try to steal it and this has actually
happened to smaller block chains where
somebody would attack the network with
more with a 51% attack and they would
actually steal bitcoins from the network
so that's that's why it's very important
that our consensus algorithms actually
are taking the account that people are
going to be bad and really quick so like
I said before raft is really good for
kind of systems that have trusted peers
so if you're in a bank and maybe you
have a private blockchain for a bank or
and it's only between blanks something
like raft is probably okay so JPMorgan
actually has their own blockchain and
NGO called quorum and they actually use
draft and
and there cuz they're in a mostly
private mostly trusted environment right
so that kind of works for them for us we
build very public block chains for games
and while there's not as much economic
incentive to try to cheat in a game a
lot of gamers really love that she and
love to attack the network and they
would love it if they were able to like
make themselves the winner of every game
so underneath ours we use a tender mint
which is a Byzantine fault-tolerant
system once again written and go it's
really amazing for this kind of purpose
so wow this is like a lot of stuff so I
did want to just touch on this because
you have to see this like you can't have
a blockchain talk and not have a Merkel
tree slide and then everybody's gonna
smile and be like all that looks really
impressive and they're like okay I'm not
gonna really care what that is but but
basically just like the 10-second
overview of anybody out or ask you what
a Merkle tree is or whatever if anybody
ever asks you out a blockchain you just
spout this about Merkel trees and then
they'll think you're really smart so
basically the whole premise of a
blockchain is that each block we
generate a hash so maybe it's a sha-3
hash it could be a sha-1 hash whatever
and then each of the blocks that combine
we take hashes of those hashes and then
we ultimately make the tree and then
that way we can we can detect that the
network is secure because we keep taking
hashes of hashes so even if even if we
have like we can validate that some
piece of data is correct without having
to compute all of it because we can see
that all the hashes match on all the
nodes and that's basically really all
you need to know about Merkle trees is
that it's basically just the tree of
hashes that actually ultimately map up
to each other and if you can say that
then everybody will think that you're an
expert on the blockchain and you'll
actually be ahead about 99% of all
blockchain developers so cool I'm just
gonna touch on this lightly because I
feel like this talk is gone very deep
but I do want to just show one or two
pictures of like what of what the
architecture of an actual blockchain is
from like the actual developer
standpoint and I know a lot of people
here or probably just be writing smart
contracts but I think like I like to
know the architecture of my sequel even
though I didn't build my sequel right so
what's kind of interesting is it looks
like a very traditional database so or a
clustered database anyways right so at
the very bottom we have a p2p layer and
that's what we talked about with raft
and we talked about with tender mint and
the p2p layer and the consensus are kind
of combined because there's more than
just the p2p we have economic consensus
which we talked about the next level is
where it kind of gets interesting where
it's kind of like you start to build
your own database so we we actually use
level DB but you could use you can
conceptually use any database but
basically what you're doing is you're
keeping it you're keeping a database of
all the transactions all the blocks and
then all the state for all of you of all
the of all the smart contracts because
basically what happens is all it is is
all the blockchain is is a giant mutable
key value store at the end of the day
and all this other stuff is kind of just
fluff above and beyond above and below
the the key value store either we have
coins but coins are just a hash table
inside of our inside of our key value
store essentially and then that the you
know that's when we're talking about
materialized views and then some block
chains have special query layers so
what's kind of really interesting is
with a blockchain it's a database that
can go backwards in time so you could
say that on July 13th how much money did
this person have between these dates how
many transactions happens right because
it's a blockchain this is a it's
actually it's a database that stores the
history forever
so you can always query it at any point
in time just kind of interesting and for
the storage layer it's kind of there's a
lot of really common options and go like
leveldb
rocks DB
sequel light bolt to be we use leveldb
just simply because it's the most well
supported key value store basically in
the go ecosystem I know a lot of people
now have moved on to rocks and Bolton
they're all really good options but
these are really fun to has anybody here
ever needed to use a key value store and
go like just like a rocky value store a
couple what reasons did you have okay
yeah that's that's actually a really
good reason to have to build your own
local cache and yeah having your own
Redis we found that like a lot of times
our go apps were a lot faster than
reddest and going over the network yeah
it's the same with you with actually
storing it in level DB so I kind of want
to tie this together I know this is like
a very broad talk but I kind of wanted
just to give an overview because I know
a lot of people here haven't used block
chains before you didn't know what they
were for you didn't understand like does
is it actually relevant to go developers
and it just kind of wanted to like walk
through and show hey there are some real
use cases you know if you're building
games if you're building things around
digital currency there's a lot of
interesting ways or if you're trying to
fight funding for a start-up there's a
lot of interesting new economic ways
where you can fund applications through
the blockchain and we're seeing a huge
revolution in people raising ten fifteen
million dollars overnight for their
blockchain applications so there's so
there's a lot of opportunity even just
in that aspect but there's a lot of
gotchas so I started this with a bunch
of flowery language about how block
chains are great but block chains are
way more difficult than using a regular
database so if you have a choice and
you're building a normal application
don't use a block chain I know you just
wasted I just wasted 40 minutes to tell
you not to use the blockchain
sorry so so we we actually have one of
our first projects was we built a stack
overflow on top of the blockchain so
basically the idea was that you would
build comments and posts and karma on
the blockchain and then as people
uploaded you you would get tokens as
rewards and you could use those tokens
to get money or other prizes and things
like this
it was like an incentivized system on
top of the blockchain so like that
aspect of it worked really well but then
we had lots of issues so like all of a
sudden the consensus on our database
would break when you have my sequel my
sequel doesn't break that often it
occasionally breaks and but when you
actually have to dig in and try to like
debug the PDP layer of your database you
start to question your decisions on how
to use a blockchain right so we were
obviously paving the way because we were
kind of one of the first people trying
to build large-scale applications in the
blockchain and what we're trying to hope
is that we help start to mitigate some
of these issues where we make it easier
to debug like consensus issues debug
like databases not being in sync with
each other because on top of it being a
distributed database like Cassandra you
have all these other implications of
security too and at the moment it's
still early days but what's kind of cool
is if you like really fun challenges and
you'd like to build big pieces of
infrastructure there's a lot of really
awesome challenges that people are still
not tackling yet and I just want to I
want to kind of leave some time for
questions so I just want to wrap it up
pretty quickly here basically there are
times when you want to build the custom
block chains so this is taco is and we
build chains that are custom they're not
like the main bitcoin they're not the
main aetherium they're custom block
chains that interact and partner with
other chains like aetherium
but they're application-specific block
chains hopefully from this talk you got
at least some of the ideas of like how
to get started building one and go kind
of just a general overview and really
just to know that they aren't this magic
solution because obviously we hear it
everywhere
probably everywhere you read online that
we should use blockchains for everything
and just really quick with loom Network
we have a blockchain programming
hackathon this weekend in London and
then the weekend after we have one in
New York I that's probably a lot less
likely but if you guys want to come feel
free to hit me up and I'll guys get you
guys entrance but it's kind of a lot of
fun we usually do gaming blockchains so
like usually over a weekend we spend 48
hours just coding games so it's a lot of
fun so cool I'll leave it for some
questions alright so I think the concept
of like the owning the assets for the
games are really cool I mean I play a
lot of games own the sword sell the
swords that kind of stuff but you said
people can fork it so aren't you
concerned about like the competition you
take all this time to build up this game
and then what happens when somebody says
ok I can take this content and build a
better game like how do you protect that
Wow the first question is really the
hardest so yeah actually so publishers
are have been the most reluctant that's
why we're a tech company but we're
building one of the first games not
because we wanted to be a game studio
but because it was a hard sell but one
of the things that's happening is games
are pre selling items to fund the game
so for us we pre-sold about a half
million u.s. dollars worth of items in
the game and we didn't even do that good
I mean that's ok but like one of our
competitors just so 2 million dollars in
items in a game that has not had a lined
code written yet so there is this there
so basically what players are saying is
is that they believe that the there
could be economic value and these items
later on so they'll help pre fund the
game so that takes a lot of the economic
risk out for the publisher so that's the
main thing so can people fork it and
steal it yes but there's there's there's
there are other plusses and stuff
that for the publisher awesome cool
other questions yep don't block chains
like slow down when they get bigger and
have more transactions and how do you
mitigate that
that's an awesome that's an awesome
thing so don't block chains get slower
as time yeah so it's a database that
stores the entire history of time so
what there is there's a couple
techniques where either you can compress
portions of time so so what some people
will do is they'll say after a certain
point we have a merkel hash from 90 days
ago and we're gonna say that all the
data before that we're gonna dump we're
gonna remove from the chain if somebody
has a backup of it they can verify that
that at that point that that was what
the data and we can just store it from
that on but because we're keeping track
of it at all times even if we lose some
of the historical data will still have
the Merkel hashes at different points to
know that this is still the same tree so
for our chains that's what we intend on
doing we're probably only going to keep
like three or four months of data
because more than that on a game isn't
that relevant cool other questions just
following up from that obviously for the
gaming you're gonna throw away the
gaming data cuz it's not so important
but in sort of financial scenarios where
people want or contract basis whereas
real value there would you not want a
historical and what people doing about
it yeah so definitely so most so most of
the the major block chains like Bitcoin
and areum haven't ever thrown away data
at some point they'll probably come into
a situation where they'll have to
because they'll have just grown too
large but I think what will happen is
that there can be third parties that
could just store it forever right so
like I used to work in the financial
world and like one of the services we
offered was 10-year storage in a vault
right and maybe at some point somebody
will do that with blockchains but right
now we just copy the entire data set
other questions
somebody nobody care one - all right
cool thank you guys
[Applause]